I need to be careful in these shorts mmm
I love these shorts like the other week
mm-hmm and like you really show us a lot
not that much you wear shorts a lot not
that much
well have worn the other day just wear
them exclusively when you see me no man
well like I wore them the other day for
a podcast and then I sat like this hmm
and then like I look back it and it was
just dick the entire time was just dick
and today I'm commando so it's gonna be
even more dick somebody sit alone though
why my commando yeah because I what you
call it because I've got routine in a
gym hmm so like its thingamajig it's Jim
hmm
I wear the same boxes that I wore to
work at the gym Bob's obviously
different clothes I bring a spare pair
of shorts because I'm gonna put the
second pair on when I'm showered but I
don't bring a spare pair of boxes
because that's just like a waste of
boxes like I'm not gonna know I'm not
gonna put a fresh pair of boxers on then
once I'm showered and then get home and
then take them off and then put them on
again tomorrow yeah well yeah that's
what you do so you right so you go to
the gym all right you start your day no
you guys you go to the gym yeah you
shower yeah you put on new boxes yeah
you wear those boxes you know go to
sleep wake up you know don't change him
what's hurting for a shower because
you'd have a shower like no for then go
through the day overweight I'm still
wearing the same boxes that I wore after
the shower in the gym the next day in
the morning
what cuz I slept in them all night you
how much you sweat during the night I
don't know I mean like a human mm-hmm
amer out of it cool man anyway let's
talk was it cool Ian once upon a time in
Hollywood
I feel like you're gonna say negative
stuff and I'm actually nervous about it
because we watch that scene and then you
were like if I ever you have a very poor
impression I have a critique about this
one scene when I thought was like one of
the best scenes of the movie I have a
critique about that scene because it was
one of the best things in the movie and
it it had a single point of alright cool
so how do you want to do this you want
to like do you want to like go from
begin in the end what do you want to do
just like around about this is my
opinion and I'm gonna give you details I
want to start because I just want you to
tell me straight up how did you feel
about the film how did you like it give
me your like highlights okay or
lowlights did you not like it perhaps I
loved it hmmm I thought was awesome
mm-hmm
I'd say what I thought was awesome I
thought it was awesome because so you
see how like it's like a Tarantino movie
right mm-hmm I only realized in this
movie that like I don't ever cool
something unless it's like a Steven
Spielberg movie but even then I don't
call it did you go see that new Steven
Spielberg movie but you definitely call
it or did you see that Tarantino movie
yeah I go you mean so I mean even in the
marketing for this
it was Tarantino's ninth film yeah you
know Spielberg on now makes films he's
made who cares like he's made a lot of
films but it's like it's almost like it
doesn't really it's like a Star Wars
film almost it's like episode 9 it's
like Tarantino's ninth films like nice
I've been waiting for this
yeah even know what who's coming out I
didn't know what was gonna be but now I
know it's a thing I'm gonna see it
because I love Tarantino films yeah but
I think it's none of their own yeah like
this is the thing I think I realized in
this movie because it had some real-life
context hmm I think it was like oh these
are why these are cool Tarantino movies
because I finally realized her in this
movie it's like Tarantino takes this
concept that is real life which is a
manager imagination behind it and you're
like I can't wait to see what he comes
up with yeah after you model you [ __ ]
together
whereas I don't think about other
directors like that I just think like
make the movie date I think there are
some directors gives you rights as well
I think that makes it different
so it's him it's his child yeah I think
there are some directors who have you
know obviously a very distinctive style
and you know you may choose say where's
Anderson his films are not necessarily
similar but you can spot always Anderson
I don't know what the [ __ ] was Anders
and his if you see an isle of dogs like
fantastic mr. Fox no I've seen like
seven minutes of fantastic mr. Fox
they're all like [ __ ] wallace and gromit
style movies I mean it's a choice yeah
yeah so yeah I could type yeah I know
it's intentional yeah have you seen and
I you know it's not always Anderson film
but I say it's a very similar style you
seen the film Columbus oh dude i watch
the film combos like two days ago
yeah I'd say that was a very similar
sort of cinematography to what is we see
you know you see sort of long shot sort
of these very they almost look dull like
you know when you've got the Marriott's
in that town in Columbus wearing it like
it looks a bit like a dull bleak but not
it's not bleak it's just so very vanilla
it looks very vanilla yeah where's
Anderson has a source has that sort of
style and you know his films aren't
necessarily about the same things
they've you know very often about very
different things yeah you can spot very
where's Anderson themes for our films
now Tarantino I would argue that his
films are not only you know they're not
they're similar that's very similarly
shot but they also have very different
storylines but they have very common
themes gore gore gore for sure you know
yeah yeah and you just waiting like do
as this gore gonna come you know and
it's sort of at this point you know you
understand it's gonna be gratuitous and
you know it's gonna be a little bit
cartoonish but it's something that has
been so heavily associated with
Tarantino that you kind of that's part
of what you expect I think I would be
disappointed to see a film that did not
have some level of violence in it oh
dude for sure so like sweet so you like
the movie you're supposed uh meals
oh right yeah I like the movie man so
yeah obviously I've got to see a
rendition of what Tarantino likes to
with the concept like hey put the twist
on it I like the gory bit and where you
are aware of the history the backstory
yeah yeah before the like not massively
but because I had heard before I saw the
film I was hearing everyone's critique
about how like Tarrant trusts Tarantino
to make like a very female based horror
story about two male heroes saving the
day but yeah I mean I feel like I mean I
get onto that later on I think but I
think that is such a reductive point do
you know the film is about is about
Sharon Tate ya know but it's it's it's
not the movies about what it movies
about
yeah the movies about what Tarantino
decided the movie was about and he just
happened to have a lady called Sharon
Tate in there who didn't get murdered
exactly so um so yeah loved the movie
loved okay I tell you what I loved about
it mmm was the very much like
relationship between Leo and his
stuntman hmm it was almost Fight Club
esque hmm in that if someone turned
around at the end of the movie and was
like I'll by the way Brad Pitt's
character wasn't real he was like a
figment of the imagination but like I
make sense yeah I can see that yeah it
almost feels like they are there they've
got a very pure friendship yeah yeah
about the film and it's and I think at
any point in that film you expected Brad
Pitt's character cliff you expected him
to some for some reason resent you know
being the stunt man or isn't Rick Dalton
and there's actually one bit way almost
it almost teases it where you have that
flashback scenario of him sort of
ruminating about the fact that Rick
Dalton wasn't willing to put him up for
to get stunt work and then he has a
flashback to when he him and Bruce Lee
had that fight and you know after that
whole long sort of segue you know he
sort of just goes yeah fair enough
wait you know you expect some sort of
resentment there you guys I get it right
you know yeah man for sure and like I
so like the scene like the purity of the
scene where he's like like Don was just
like a child hmm and in the whole thing
and you kind of wait in for cliff hmm so
just like very much like for [ __ ] sake
and like I'm tired of like taking care
of this kid and it's kind of pissing me
off
as like he is just like winning at life
and doesn't even appreciate it and I'm
full of [ __ ]
and but I think I'm big Bubba but but
like then you have the scene where he's
like oh you want to come in and watch
like my FBI episode and he was like dude
I just assumed that was what we were
doing was like friends oh yeah I think a
lot of that comes from the fact that
cliff as a character you off see
understands that Rick Dalton isn't super
successful not as much as you'd like to
be true doesn't have the friends that
you would expect true and you know is
very insecure so I think you know the
fact of the matter is that they are
cliff because cliff understands his the
various floors of Rick Dalton can you
like do that arm closer to the hold on
oh yeah yeah because he doesn't because
he understands how flawed Rick Dalton is
as a character he doesn't resent him
because he you know he understands that
he doesn't have all the things that he
would want true that's true and thing is
like yeah yeah that's true and yet like
you said about the whole kind of
flashback scene is just like he
understands why he's kind of in the [ __ ]
pit there years and he also kind of
stands that he's a stuntman and that
means nothing to anyone ever
well he's a stuntman but he also doesn't
ever actually aspire to more than that
at some point in the film in a fairly
early on in the film even says because
he's quite clearly happy with handiwork
you know he even says you know I don't
mind driving you I quite like driving
you around like you know he's not he's
not he never he doesn't want to be an
actor he doesn't want to be famous he
doesn't want you know anyway he just
wants to be
Rick's friend you know just wants steady
employment
yeah duty be fair he doesn't ever
actually
show any real passion towards being a
stunt man he just happens to be a stunt
man and if he has to not be a stunt man
and be a handyman then he's like yeah
that's cool too as long as I can go as
long as I can like afford like packet
mac and cheese to eat and enough dog
food to feed my [ __ ] beast of a dog
like I'm chill dude and then he kind of
looks at like the real aspects of his
life and you can just tell he's like
dude my life's [ __ ] sick
and I was actually dog this is actually
like talking about this to like my
friend the other day like I was talking
about like in order to like happiness
and I can order to be truly happy
you can like if you're not like if
you're if you're never gonna be rich
hmm or if you never like if you're never
ever gonna be like financially sound
yeah the only way to be truly happy is
to like really accept not like just like
I'm never gonna be rich but like
actually truly accept like I did I'm
never gonna be rich and you're like nice
like this is chill so when he is she he
looks you can tell he looks at like the
nice sides of his from an outside
perspective [ __ ] life he's like dude I
get to drive a sick car all day
he's like my I'm best friends with like
a movie star see cool people all the
time like he flies me out to [ __ ]
Italy just cuz and it's just like I do
boring stuff all day I'm not stuck in an
office I go home chill and the next days
you never know man I'm picking up sweet
hitchhikers in this awesome car and I'm
just son just and just driving man yeah
and you know I think this film shows
both characters throughout as being you
know having very few ulterior motives
they are both pretty much on the surface
good guys you know they both in their
own ways will have flaws but they're not
in any way you know this unlikable
characters dude and they're super
likable characters and they're kind of
polar opposites in a way as well even
though they're like best friends in that
what we just said about cliff kind of
being extremely content about his like
really run-of-the-mill life and you got
like Rick Dalton who is on the complete
opposite end of the spectrum who
detests his life and is even resentful
of the jobs that he gets hmm and like
he's resentful the jobs he gets he's
presented as a job that he doesn't get
and is like he wants so much more from
his life but he doesn't realize that he
literally has everything and he's just
like he didn't give a [ __ ] about the job
take like that cowboy job that he had
but he didn't give a [ __ ] about it when
he had it and then he's pissed that he
doesn't have it
yeah and it's just like he hates
everything yeah I guess but you know I
think he's sort of reached that point in
his life where he he feels like he
should have been able to do more yeah
because I think part of the point of
this film is to show that he is actually
a talented actor as Oda he has actually
got much more range than the characters
that he's betrayed and he hasn't hasn't
had never had the opportunity to show
that you know there is there is
obviously the part of the film where he
you know he even here to himself sort of
has been pigeon-holed and he doesn't
feel like you know he should be playing
that villain he doesn't like that
they're hiding his face yeah yeah and
you know he's not being portrayed in the
in the way he's always usually been
because he's been stuck in that same
role so that same mindset for so long
but in actuality he does have the range
to do more so part of his frustrations
it's not it's not that he's you know
just some some actor who he feels like
he should do more but doesn't actually
have a lot he does have more to
contribute but he doesn't he's never had
the opportunity to do so and he sort
they're very fearful that he might not
ever get the opportunity to do so nice
man nice so what you actually talked
about your favorite bit yeah my favorite
bit I mean you've not here we go of your
highlights highlights right sweet so
highlights were like little nuances like
what I said when he said are you gonna
come and watch my FBI and he's like
doing I just assume that's what we were
doing like but you enjoy a bromance I
king love bromance like dude pure
friendship is hard to find man and it's
just like two dudes that really enjoy
each other's company I'm just like dude
[ __ ] jealous yeah and what else what
else did I love so fairy bits were that
bit
the scene that we spoke about already
mm-hmm I don't know if you want to join
me to talk about later okay cool so the
scene where my criticism of that seam is
probably not why you expect me it to be
but and it's not even a big thing okay
cool so love the scene where he's doing
his thing forgets the lines and he's
getting outrageously stressed because
you can literally see that he thinks his
career slipping away in front of his own
hands about the job that he really
didn't even want to do he's doing it and
he's actually like [ __ ] I'm doing a [ __ ]
job over this I'm doing a [ __ ] job of
this [ __ ] job I does I don't even
deserve to get this [ __ ] job but I
didn't even want like I'm the [ __ ]
shitty sector and then he has a mental
breakdown in his trailer ruins is [ __ ]
says this is due to the drinkie and his
dude is is completely down to drinking
I'm never [ __ ] drinking again and
then he immediately out of habit takes a
sip at his flask [ __ ] first of Lascaux
he's just like flat like you can tell if
he had a gun he just shooting something
that yeah and but then he's like
completely and utterly nails it after
that yeah and you know I think it showed
a lot about his character it showed that
he is you know I'd like I said before he
can do more but he really takes acting
seriously he is not lazy and you get
those scenes earlier on way is
practicing his lines and he says
specifically and that seems like you
know you practice it you press it and
now they think you didn't yeah they
think I didn't put in the work and I did
yeah he's a courageous he paranoid yeah
and you know he's he's upset because he
feels like he's embarrassed himself and
you know that is a fantastic scene you
know great well I'm probably the best
thing of them yeah it's amazing
my criticism was that scene is you only
camera walk purely camera like and this
is why there is a point in that scene
from you know for a little while but
he's shouting at himself in the mirror
how oh I know what you're gonna say he's
looking at the mirror from this angle
but the cameras catching it from this
angle so from a point of view they
obviously decided that they wanted you
to be able to see his face
however all that highlighted to me was
the fact that he's obviously not looking
at himself in the mirror he's looking at
the camera yeah okay
and I thought I was like I remember that
scene yeah i'm i was like this is
distracting his because i can you know
you can sort of put yourself and
abstract i was like i know he's just
shouting into the distance like you know
nothing because i can see his face which
means he can't see his face
yeah so that's true and so that i found
for me personally and it's not it's
probably not something a lot of people
thought a lot about but as soon as i
noticed it it was distracting for me
because i couldn't unsee it because am i
is like oh he's just doing that and then
maybe it distracted me from the rest of
the scene so but do you never do ever
this is obviously pretty far-fetched do
you not think it might be like a
tarantino double bluff where it's like a
understated fourth wall effect and he's
like like you said earlier made
reference to the fact that his movies
are quite cartoonish we're watching
Leonardo act at being an actor and that
it's blatantly obvious that he hid the
angle that we're looking at doesn't make
sense it's possible but unlikely I mean
you know I feel like you can make
excuses for it for sure you could say
well I mean that I'd I knew about it
when I watched it and that I did didn't
come into my head until just now so I'm
assuming that probably wasn't the case
cuz I just made that up on the spot you
never know for me I found it personally
distracting okay fair enough
you know but otherwise the scene was
great I think the scene before that on
its own was fantastic with him for
getting his lines and you know just the
the shots in general because also it did
that that particular scene did something
that doesn't happen a lot in films is it
made you aware of cinematography as a
concept because that scene had you know
which was what was being shot was you
know a movie set film a TV set and it
really you know they played the scene
out he's acting the scene they did the
camera rotation and then they addressed
my own I gave rotate the camera back and
then when they do the scene again you
know you like yes
something that is doing yeah dude but he
addressed that and you think wow dude
that was [ __ ] sick it was it really
soft brought and you know it made the
whole scene a lot more because you could
appreciate the the camera more goes into
it the the hot the focus on the you know
from character to character we're moving
the camera around yeah man there's new
level of focus that's true because all
the other sets that he does they don't
make any reference to whether we're
looking through we're looking at a set
hmm because you can't see other cameras
so we don't know if what camera we're
looking for are we looking for you
Tarantino's camera or we were looking
through Jeff from camera to camera on
the actual set so when they do that like
back step yeah I was just like yeah and
in general you know it really does
highlight the fact that I think if
anything one of the main features of
Tarantino's films is the cinematography
because it is it is something that
throughout you know all of his films
disintegrate he is fantastic it goes all
the way back to when you have say Kill
Bill where you have certain shots that
are unachievable unless you actively you
know if you if you really think about
some of the shots you know they'll go
forward they'll go back and then he goes
up to somewhere where you just recently
saw there was a roof which means during
the shot the roof was removed then the
camera can yeah yeah
all throughout all Tarantino films you
have these sorts of intricate shots
where if you only appreciate similar
ography you know wow that was fantastic
and that was just you know a little
easter egg of its own into the small
small interest to photography details
that make up some of these films so
personally and you haven't asked me yet
I did obviously loved the film okay I do
office Lille off the film I don't have a
lot of criticisms about it do you want
however I know and I don't know how well
you know it's received I know quite a
few people who didn't like it at all
I know I know of I haven't really spoken
to that many people about it I know one
person he didn't know anything
about it uh my fear about the film is
that it's too Tarantino hmm in that that
if you aren't watching it because it's a
Tarantino movie that it's very easy not
to enjoy okay so in that I supposed to
lose by it
hmm and he was like it's very much like
what the [ __ ] if you say Luis didn't
know anything about the Sharon Tate
murders okay and he doesn't know
anything about Quentin Tarantino movies
so from his perspective it's very much
like what the [ __ ] is this film about
right for one when is it gonna end
because I don't know there's no kind of
obvious this is yeah this is the
Middle's the this is the end this is
where we there it doesn't lead to
anywhere where is because I knew about
the murders on a knew the film was about
the murders I knew it was leading there
but if I didn't know that I also would
be thinking what the [ __ ] is going and I
would still enjoy it because I'm
enjoying the cinematography for one
we're joining the acting and I'm
enjoying just like what's going on in
each scene I can enjoy scenes
individually from a Tarantino movie
because I enjoyed those kind of movies
and I like you said I look for the
Easter eggs I look for the little subtle
nuances I like the bromances I like the
emotional kind of impact of each
individual scene and I don't have to
always tie it up until I don't always
have to tie up the film until it's done
and then once it's done I can tie it up
whereas the average movie watcher might
be like what the [ __ ] is this film like
literally what is it hmm
what is it about cuz it's called Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood you assume it's
about something but up until
ninety-seven percent of the movie it's
not about anything I can understand that
um I don't think that it's not about
anything in the same way I don't think
Pulp Fiction is not about anything you
know Columbus the film
what a shame happens in that film true
that films about nothing but is it a
good film absolutely it's good fun you
know yeah but I like it mmm it's a good
feel I like it but I don't know if many
other people that I know I don't know
that any many people that I know who
were average movie watchers would like
Columbus in fact I'm pretty certain a
lot of people that I know that average
movie watchers wouldn't like Columbus
because it's about [ __ ] all right but
then I suppose why Wow what makes her
feel good
why are films good because I to watching
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood I
fortunately so obviously me Lauren we
the other day maybe three weeks ago
watched the hateful eight it's her first
time watching it and then two days
before watching Worcester long time in
Hollywood watch the inglorious basterds
so I'm already in the Tarantino frame of
mind
I know what to expect and I know what
not to expect I know the sort of things
you know linear storytelling you know
there will be occasionally shots or
scenes I think that don't really go
anywhere maybe they develop a character
but they are they sort of ignore very
classic storytelling tropes oh yeah I
just scenes for the sake of scenes
sometimes for the sake of acting
sometimes for the sake of a shot
sometimes for the sake of letting you
know more about the character but about
the character that's not especially
relevant you know that's sort of what
Tarantino does now all of these films in
some way they subvert very traditional
storytelling narratives and to some
extent those films are good because of
that because they are unexpected in the
same way that a plot twist can sometimes
be good because it's unexpected and Wow
that makes for a good story in some of
the ways that Tarantino makes his films
nonlinear the story dough doesn't follow
the first second third act
you know progression is it good because
it is surprising is it bad because it
doesn't follow traditional storytelling
mmm fair enough
what I find is with most
people they will you know decide I know
you know what Tarantino films are about
and we can watch a talented film go wow
that was a really good Tarantino film
but if we watch though that film on its
own would we like it well but I also -
almost rebuttal but also agree in other
Tarantino movies that do that same thing
he purposely puts you in a position that
you can digest that so for one Pulp
Fiction
is about nothing but he makes that
obvious that is about nothing because we
have a million different serve
characters within a million different
stories so once we've moved to Bruce
Willis we've never seen Bruce Willis
before so we accept the fact that it
might not have anything to do with
anything else that's happened so far and
that happens when we see Samuel Jackson
with what's his Jesus John Travolta and
then we've got John Travolta of uma
Thurman that we've never seen before so
we can digest the fact that this films
probably not going anywhere and if it
does go anywhere it won't get tied up to
the very end because we've got all these
other people to digest so we can
actually get ourselves mentally in a
position to focus on character
development focus on the kind of
substance that's Pulp Fiction
hey hey they put us in a position in
that even if it isn't linear
and even if is character development for
the sake of character development even
though it doesn't relate to the linear
story well you also know that everyone's
locked in a cabin and they almost give
us the reap like at the beginning of
hateful a even though there's loads of
[ __ ] that happens in hateful a and many
stories and kind of tangents and
everything about that doesn't relate to
the actual story
they've set us off with the premise
there's a murder in here we need to find
out who it is mm-hmm so even though all
that other stuff is happening we can
enjoy that because we actually know what
the films about so for the average non
Tarantino fan for one pulp fiction we
can digest it easier for too hateful a
we know what the films about because
they've already told us what the films
about so we can accept the fact that
loads of other bogus [ __ ] goes on all
and it doesn't matter if I don't like
the other [ __ ] because I know what the
films about all right Once Upon a Time
in
would does neither of those things do
you think that film that once upon a
time about her in Hollywood is about
nothing no I don't think it's about
nothing but I think that it doesn't
directly tell you what it's a it might
be about nothing well it might it's it's
about nothing there I mean because I
don't even agree necessarily that it it
completely you know ignores traditional
storytelling it presents you with the
character in the very first scene Rick
Dalton who's given a an opportunity to
be in a film that he doesn't necessarily
want it establishes very early on that
he's not satisfied with his career and
wants to do more it also establishes
that he lives next door to Roman
Polanski and you know that and he wants
to be in a Roman Polanski movie yeah
cool and then throughout the film it
shows that Rick Dalton and you know
cliff by extension genuine guys who you
know taking in Rick's case has the
ability to do a lot more and you know
clearly is a victim of just being
pigeon-holed you know he's not not
achieving because he can't do more he's
not achieving because he's been
pigeonhole into these characters you
know these Western sort of Sheriff for
whatever characters and ultimately he's
not going to get out of that so he
embraces that Indian because he sort of
accepts his lot in life you know this is
what I'm gonna do this is the Hawkeye
again he displays that he has real
acting talent but he's probably not
gonna get any further and then finally
the film establishes you know just
through sheer luck maybe and through a
bit of a bit of savvy bit of you know
defending him and his wife you know
through complete opportunity he then
ends up interacting with Sharon Tate and
the suggestion being to go on that he
becomes friends with Sharon and is
potentially going to advance his career
later on so the film okay you know what
you've actually changed
from that actually standpoint you
actually changed my mind I think the
reason I said the film was about nothing
was because it's somewhat based around
the Sharon Tate murder
this is hmm so that in my mind it almost
makes everything about the relationship
between Rick and cliff and his career
aspirations and lack of on cliffs part
and all of these things irrelevant
because in my mind that's technically
what not
he's our fallenness to trap in saying
that yeah that's not what the movie is
about because the movies about this even
though no technically the movie is
actually not about that but that is the
only kind of real thing that's actually
happened hmm so it's hard to not think
that that's what the movie is about and
that is also the climax of the movie but
the movies the movie is very little to
do with the Sharon Tate murders it
establishes who Shantae is as a
character and it and it does so in such
a way in the city in a very similar to
Maine to inglorious basterds it it
builds an association with Sharon Tate
it wants you to have some investment in
her because as everyone who knows
anything about the Sharon Tate murder
you know you're building up investment
to suddenly take it away and that's when
it finally subverts that and does the
same thing that English bastard does and
just as an alternative version of
history where in fact that did not
happen and you know it goes on a
completely different course of events
just you know it surprised the audience
and it's like quite you know it's very
entertaining but ok fair these you know
it's quite novel but it does have a very
you know a very obvious storyline and it
is the progression of Rick Dolan from
being somewhat of a husband to being
someone who has the opportunity now to
make a real difference in you know in
Hollywood and to be a big player and
nuts because a it shows that he deserves
it because he is there actually a good
actor he's actually a good person and he
just finally gets an opportunity from
out nowhere you know from their already
established Chekhov's gone off he lives
next door to Roman Polanski you know he
just needs an opportunity
and saving Sharon Tate's life that's the
opportunity fair play man
good synopsis of the movie didn't think
about that way question did I'm gonna
follow it up with my own interpretations
of why he did this mmm but dear
Tarantino need to cast margot robbie as
Sharon Tate what are your reservations
about him casting murderer me it's not
that I have reservations about casting
Margot Robbie it's more about the fact
that I don't have I don't know this is
the thing right I don't know why I'm
asking this question hmm
but basically the way that the facts are
the facts and it's almost just because
of who she is and I guessed from an
artistic standpoint doesn't matter who
you are hmm from the fact of who she is
it's almost a disservice to someone of
her caliber to put her in such a role
that didn't need to be played by her
John I'm seen you saying that Margot
Robbie is an actress was wasted in a
character who didn't have a lot in the
film not necessarily as an that's the
thing actually I'm not even saying she
was wasted as an actress I'm more saying
she was wasted as a celebrity she was
wasted as a celebrity because she sells
tickets mm-hmm but she sought and she
sold tickets for this movie hmm for the
non artistic fans but she was we didn't
need her sure to do that role she did
nothing in the movie basically and what
what I'm trying to say is that yeah it
was almost an intentional waste of
celebrity to get her to play that role
we didn't need her and in
my mind I kind of just to follow up I
kind of thought he intentionally because
Sharon Tate is a celebrity he maybe
almost used an actual celebrity to
represent the fact that she is a
celebrity sure in in that universe in
that universe you say that Margot Robbie
has that natural stardom of you know we
need someone who is a celebrity mother
obviously everyone knows who Margot
Robbie is you know who could portray
some you know an up-and-coming star
better than and an up-and-coming star
that's what I'm trying to say yeah
that's exactly what I'm trying to say
and I guess and that respect he nailed
it and I guess it is like her role
wasn't big enough for the film so and I
guess it's just like it I guess I don't
know I guess it's just like more like
I'm just thinking like stupid thoughts
in that like it's a waste of budget you
could have saved yourself millions of by
just getting someone else and just with
a little bit of more oomph yeah we could
have got like a much not lesser actress
cuz her talent is her talent and I'm
sure there's plenty of people that have
her talents I'm not even talking from a
talent standpoint but from a financial
standpoint in a celebrity standpoint and
been if versus benefit to the movie mmm
it's just like I don't understand where
you've gone with it but was it necessary
but I guess commentor Tina's at some
point is what's necessary isn't it
what's necessary and it's also not the
first time he's done it to take back to
their hateful a who's Channing Tatum
yeah good point man he had a very small
role dude you know to be fair Channing
Tatum what I think was a big he wasn't
on the title cards he wasn't you know
marketed to be a big part of the film
but they did have you know he did have
talent and come into the film 75% of the
way through it and more kill them off 82
percent of the way through it yeah
Channing Tatum was in that film for a
very short period of
I'm kind of near the end did that
actually reach out to him absolutely
[ __ ] not it could have been any back
literally could have been and that could
be me good I'm in you I could have
played 10 Titans Roundhill a good point
definitely didn't need to be channeling
him but but the difference with that is
you can believe that Channing Tatum took
that role because he wanted to be in a
Tarantino movie you can convince
yourself that Channing Tatum asked to do
a challenging the movie and was willing
to take that role hmm for this one you
can you obviously know that wasn't the
case but I don't even necessarily think
that Margaery had a small role in the
film well that's a lot that's the
argument for a lot of people and asked
her own argument as well but because not
only not even I think because even take
into account the fact that in terms of
not in terms of screen time but screen
time alone there was plenty of scenes
with Margot Robbie as the only real
character you know rare thing going on
you have this sort of star power of you
know the DiCaprio and Brad Pitt sharing
screen time constantly Margot Robbie is
there anyone that really had her own
story is strictly separate but dialogue
though dialogue shed like six lines in
the entire film I mean you know it's
dialogue necessarily he's like yeah you
can quantify and say maybe she didn't
have as much but once again the film
wasn't really about her you sure you
needed to have establishing shots
because like I said before I think what
Tarantino likes to do and what you want
to do and this is a scenario similar to
inglourious basterds was to build an
association with this character with the
expectation of the audience well I not
having to Sharon Tate and he's shown me
Sharon Tate so that when he takes her
away from us
you know it's gonna be that one Dutch
Harbor and he's building this you know
association with who she is before she
gets murdered only to then subvert that
I tell you why I asked exude what you're
saying right now is actually reminding
why I asked this why I asked the
question in the first place is that it
was very obvious that that's the
intention that he's trying to do
but he actually in my opinion didn't do
a very good job job of that he didn't of
building up who Sharon Tate is so you
can take us away so that we're actually
like whoa he didn't even take her away I
don't think he did a very fantastic job
of building her up because of the lack
of dialogue we don't know who we don't
have an opinion of her because she
doesn't speak um we just going off the
fact that she's Margot Robbie
if she wasn't Margot Robbie then we
would have been like what was the point
in her even being in the movie I think a
good impression of her I think you
definitely get the impression so before
that she's an up-and-coming star only
because of the the cinema scene where
cinema seems decent let's kind of get
like a cutesy vibe yeah and you also you
understand that she is about to make be
famous mm-hmm she she gets to the ticket
booth and the woman doesn't know who she
is but soon she says who she is you know
stand by the poster it's like oh of
course that's who you are
and you know she goes to this film to
watch it just to sort of be a part of
you know everyone's having a good time
everyone's seeing her character
everyone's laughing at characters she's
like she's happy she's grateful to be
you know via partner and you know I said
she they're they're really building her
up to be you know quite a lovable
character despite the fact she doesn't
have a lot of screen time you have some
association with her so even even by the
end even by you know by the time that
Leo's met her you know that she is a
genuinely nice person
hmm you know that you know that she you
want you know you want the best for her
and you also expect that her friendship
with Leo is probably gonna mean bigger
things for him because she's such a nice
person
cool tell you about waste of celebrity
hmm didn't even think about her just now
hmm Al Pacino dude was that necessary
Al Pacino as an what did he do in that
movie nothing I mean that didn't need to
be alpha tuna that could have been
anyone Al Pacino I guess yeah but I mean
that's at this point at this point
without Pacino what is he done to be
fair
most people will never know who our
Bettina is you know what was the real
last big thing that she it's not like
you know you've taken Dwayne Johnson
away from his busy schedule of starring
in movies for a seven minute scene in a
Tarantino film you know Al Pacino you
know obviously had his day but he's not
exactly got a lot going on I know but I
also feel like if you're gonna throw out
Pacino a bone through our Al Pacino a
bone you know maybe maybe he doesn't
matter I don't I don't I don't think Al
Pacino at this point is enough to sell
tickets I don't think he's a leading man
no no that's what I'm saying but what
I'm saying is is that like I don't
expect him to sell tickets and like he
wasn't I didn't even know his in the
movie hmm but what I'm saying is is it's
one of two things either it's in terms
of the role he played it's like if Al
Pacino asked to be in that movie then
it's like he probably would have done
better off just refusing to let him in
the movie rather than given that right
it was just such a throwaway role mmm
that it was almost just like legacy wise
it's just like you could have given him
a better role like you could have
created I'm not saying you needed him to
be in multiple scenes I'm not saying you
needed him I'm just saying it's like he
has the talent and he has the legacy
that if you're gonna give him a
throwaway role he could at least be that
guy that people who don't know who our
Pacino is could at least be like dude
who was that guy that did that thing
like at least make him memorable in the
movie if you're gonna put Al Pacino as a
thrower a role in the movie I suppose
but I also think at this point Tarantino
himself is so big that he he's not
exactly begging people to be in his
films oh no I'm saying I'm saying I'm
saying like even if it was opportunist
ain't like dude I heard you're making
this big movie I'd love to be a part of
it Quentin Tarantino could easily like
unless he [ __ ] hates out Pacino he
could at least been like I did yeah like
I can draw something up for you rather
than just the random Italian
producer guy who does nothing in the
movie and it's just like that's a
disservice to Albertina in my opinion as
it deserves the opportunity to give him
that role if you wrote like if Albert
una approached Quentin Tarantino said
dude how'd you're making this movie I'm
a [ __ ] huge fan
please I'll like if you don't mind I'm
my schedules open
I'd love to come on set if you've got
something you can write for me that'd be
fantastic and he wrote that for me I
would have been like I would rather you
remember nothing I mean I just let me
watch I think especially in this film
and because you know you can take it
from the title Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood it is very much a love letter
to Hollywood itself and you know you can
expect to draw a draw some a star power
from that and you know that means that
there's not there's quite a few examples
in that film alone of stars being in
fairly small roles you know you have al
pacino you've got Kurt Russell as you
know this I mean I don't actually made
casting I'm not sure I'm sure what his
character was doing but he once again
was not in it for very long Dakota
Fanning she you know she was an in it
for very much that's one time Dakota
Fanning had a more impact for rather
than Al Pacino though yeah sure but you
know even still like you know her role
in terms of screen time real screen time
may be about the same you know Timothy
Olyphant once again still in it for
focus I mean Timmy off he was the star
of the the cowboy show that oh that guy
like that guy yeah yeah yeah you have
various characters you know various
actors really you know high-profile
actors who are in this in this film for
not a lot of time it is a the film about
Rick Don is a film about Hollywood
itself you know it's not necessarily
spending a lot of time on these actors
but I think in the case of Margaery in
case of Al Pacino yeah you could have
other people playing it but if you want
to write a film which is about Hollywood
maybe get some stars in yeah but I also
what the point I'm trying to make is in
that is that I agree yeah
film by Hollywood use Hollywood that's
perfect but only because aren't like
granted Albertina was in another
right now but what there was a time
where he was the most famous actor on
planet Earth
hmm and partly because of his ability to
act now Dakota Fanning was a superstar
at one point and yes she had barely any
screen time and but the role that she
played in like the two minutes that she
was in the film was seriously impactful
there was tension around the scene she
her talent bought something to that
movie to the point where I'm thinking
about thinking I do that to Kate finally
saying that I was actually a very decent
scene I was just saying as a tribute to
Al Pacino who clearly doesn't have
[ __ ] at all much going on in his life
right now if you're gonna give him a
character and use Hollywood utilize
Hollywood it would be nice for the
Pacino fans if you gave Pitino a role
even if it's for sixty Seconds that
could have any kind of tension to the
movie or at least let him flex his
acting muscles a little bit that have
been dormant for the last God knows how
many years I think this is a bit of an
issue in that I feel like the longest
piss ever and then like him like he's
dying down and then dude he goes you
know it's like and then Randall goes ah
and he's like a full stream again how
does that happen
like it feels like your bladder is like
multiple tanks yeah yeah yeah as soon as
the first one gets done to the bomb and
they're like yeah it's crack so for the
next myself it comes full full pressure
again you know dude I add one of the
other day the gym and it's like the
longest [ __ ] piece of my life is
going ages and they're like Louis was
like waiting for me not talking to me
because I was like the changing room
tonight and I was just going to go and
then he was just like stop mid-sentence
yes I are you still [ __ ] peace it was
like do it make sense it did that like
three times okay cool so Pacino
anything else you want to talk about in
particular mm-hmm anyway I've known
quite a few people who didn't like oh
yeah that's what you said
wide Joe is did not like the film [ __ ] I
knew no and Joe is a very you know he's
lifelong fan of Tarantino you know it
loves all those films you know the
hateful eight is a film what many people
consider to be boring because not what
happens at what takes place in one scene
Joe loves take away you know I love
hatefully Havel is intense grateful it's
intense for ages now Joe considers Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood to be a boring
film a film that is not about a lot he
didn't appreciate some of the scenes
such as the implication that cliff
killed his wife you know he thought that
scene was completely pointless because
it was never that's evil it was
completely pointless because it's never
referenced again and you know there are
various parts of the film that he just
felt well he didn't think that the whole
storyline with the hippies was important
at all you know he just all-around
didn't care from now I've spoken to a
copy parlor you know get similar vibes
people think it's you know general five
of it is is boring now you can put this
down to people misunderstanding
Tarantino however it does highlight the
broader question of what is what is film
what is cinema what makes it good
because it is one of two things it is
either an art form which is abstract and
has to be appreciated by each person
individually or is something that can be
quantified something that adheres to a
criteria can be marked against that
criteria but it can't be both because
the film is are entirely art and
interpretive and you know that's fine if
people didn't like it
you like it for for different reasons or
the things that make it good are the
quality of the shots you know the the
the how great the acting is you know how
well the storyline is and how well the
story itself sticks to a you know a
formatted schema mm-hm yeah what makes a
film good because in many many of
Tarantino's cases he ignores traditional
film formats and creates what is in the
opinion of many people to be great films
but polarizing films nonetheless yeah um
for one before I get into my opinion on
what makes a good film I just want to
say that the hippies are important
because the hippies are actually people
that did the murders and if they weren't
included in the movie then they wouldn't
make much sense for them to like I know
I'm just letting you know if you're
gonna give Joe's opinion and he's not
here when I have to just give my opinion
on Joe's opinion but I mean both agree
that Joe is wrong but yeah okay cool
right anyway just wrong
so I guess what you know what I'll tell
you why I love Tarantino movies which
also answers your question mm-hmm is
that Tarantino is one of the few people
who can make you believe that maybe good
films are an individually accepted art
form and they actually treats film as
are and that you you allow yourself
Tarantino is one of the few people who
can allow you to enjoy a film for the
sake of enjoying the film mm-hmm and it
doesn't matter like even when I said
earlier like the films about nothing
that even wasn't even a critique that's
just like I really enjoyed the movie and
there's so many parts that I can enjoy
about it and I like the fact that it
doesn't follow a traditional format I
like the fact that you can digest every
scene individually I like the fact that
goes off the off the beaten track a lot
of times I like the fact that it does
bring in things that might intrigue me
and then it never comes back to it again
I like that but then again would I like
that if I wasn't expecting that would I
like it if it wasn't a Tarantino movie
and it was just
Leonardo DiCaprio movie with Brad Pitt
in it and then I'll be like dude Leo and
Brad Pitt with tough but I'm watching it
and then I watched that not known as
Tarantino movie well I like it as much
to take today you know that to its
extreme and I know you haven't seen it
but it comes to mind to me because I
watched the disaster artist again the
other day
disaster artist is a film which is about
the make oh I've seen the disaster I
tell you yeah watch the desert sorry I
see you've not seen the room ice in the
room I watch you know one of the
criticisms of the room you know of many
criticisms and one thing that's
highlighted the disastrous is is there
are particular plot points in the room
that are introduced and they're never
addressed you know one of the most
famous example of that is one of the
characters in one scene brings up the
fact that she has breast cancer at no
point in that movie is it ever mentioned
again never again as I mentioned cool is
just as a context point if anyone has
actually listened to this thing
the room is even though I haven't seen
that the room is just like yeah it's
like categorically we're now just the
worst movie of all time
fantastic news yes fantastic exactly
so-called classic now because it's so
bad and then the disaster artist is like
James Franco's rendition of the remaking
of the room yeah the making of the room
by James Franco and it's got a little
bit more of a comedic effect but it is
like painfully accurate yeah from what I
saw from the outtakes as tough as that
yeah so yeah continue right so and you
know obviously that is a completely
independent film the director had no
nothing to go off of no you know this is
this is just classic Tommy was oh so you
know when he has these plot lines that
come out of nowhere and go nowhere feel
that all the [ __ ] mmm what does that
mean so what is the difference when
cliff booth has a flashback of him maybe
killing his wife
that has never addressed the yen and you
can sort of think well that's just a
nice bit of interesting background
character it makes you so leaves you
dismissed
what is cliff like what is his character
who knows but it doesn't act for going
here it's never addressed was it
necessary scene maybe not you know I can
choose to like that scene am i do like
that scene and I like having that bit of
mystery round cliff but why is that
different from a character injuries the
fact that she has breast cancer and then
it never be mentioned again yeah it's
not different man it's artistic license
is what it is it's the fact that I hate
M night Shyamalan and if I'm not
Shyamalan did that to me I call him
every name under the Sun there's because
in Tarantino or respect him so much and
I know I guess I feel like I've M night
Shyamalan you can reliably expect that
it will come up in a sequel 15 years
yeah true I think you know what it is I
think it's the same as barfi I also
think it's the same as all lies all
artists have a kind of method behind
their madness and if you can't get
comfortable with that so like Picasso
for example if Picasso I don't know [ __ ]
all about because well neither white but
because it right because it's the one
that did that like fire up one right or
the screams green it was painted by
Edvard Munch who did the firework one
right let me just Google a Picasso
painting for [ __ ] sake
[Music]
you type in firework Picasso doesn't
blow Picasso paintings oh no all right
because is a terrible example and right
[ __ ] who's like a really good eyes like
a Monet you know like a Monet I'm going
van Gogh mm-hmm I maybe think I did the
fire back one hang on
thank open oh yeah you're Giggy Giggy
yeah hang on yeah Vince van Gogh did the
firework thing right cool so what about
starry night huh starry night yeah it's
not fireworks or stars yes start yeah
before they were fireworks never mind
anyway
yes if you take a van Gogh painting mmm
and then when go randomly comes up and
his next big my
the piece is just a [ __ ] square
mm-hmm with like come in the middle of
it
no one's gonna appreciate that but if
you have an artist that always makes
squares would come in the middle of it
and he's got his little cult following
the negative like it's brilliant like
you have to understand the method behind
their madness and if you can't
understand it then you can't appreciate
it but that assumes that Tarantino only
has this you know because he's got such
a back catalog of great movies you know
you only appreciate I can appreciate
Tarantino movie because I at this point
know who he is and I can appreciate them
but you know take it all the way back to
pulp fiction pulp fiction is a you know
is it a very early film which has a lot
of the same stuff a lot of the same you
know storytelling tropes you know you
have scenes whereby uma farmers
character is talking about a TV show you
know that she features in a completely
irrelevant plotline yeah you've got all
of these sort of you know characters
that comment you know some of them are
reintroduced some things are just picked
up and left
you know you have nonlinear storyline
proud fiction is a perfect example of a
film that had anyone else done it had it
been told in a slightly different way
people and you know I think a lot of
people do still regard port thinking
there's not a good film but a lot of
people do think it's a good film I'm
Divi [ __ ] does you know it's my
hometown
yeah but why is it good I don't know man
it's just good it just how it makes you
feel man
because I the reason I think I'll tell
you reason why I think probably she was
good because I saw Pulp Fiction when I
was like a kid and I thought it was good
and I didn't understand film I'd just
I'm pretty sure dad just told me to
watch Pulp Fiction and I watched Pulp
Fiction I was like masks good movie and
like that was the end of it but I didn't
need to understand cinematography I
didn't eat Sam I didn't need to
understand who Quentin Tarantino was I
didn't even know Quentin Tarantino
directed that movie and even who Quinta
and Turner was I was just like ask
decent movie and it wouldn't matter if
anyone else at the time they watch it
wouldn't a man who made the movie
because I liked the movie
didn't know who Quentin Tina was mm
whereas I also feel like Quentin
Tarantino at this stage in his career is
also playing off his own benefit in that
he knows that he has more creative
license to put his trademarks in a film
and there be more well received in a way
in a in a in a different kind of film
something sense because like I said
earlier like pop fiction is the whole
thing's thrown away so you can digest it
better so he put in that early work so
there's like this is how my mind works
and this is the kind of film this is the
kind of tendencies that I have in a film
but I'm also gonna put it in a film
where the entire film revolves around
his tendencies so later on and in my
career when I make a film that has a lot
more structures and it has these
tendencies people who understand that
this is just my way and they'll accept
it better and digest it better which we
did and wasn't put on time in Hollywood
but if once upon a time in Hollywood
came out when I was a kid I'm I've been
like this film was [ __ ] boring hmm I
can see that he definitely almost
exploits the fact that he is Tarantino
yeah you can see that in Django you can
see that in good movie that was a great
movie but you know when he when Django
shoots a woman from you know hit this
angle shoot say she [ __ ] flies that
okay you know I think what the [ __ ] was
that
yeah yeah yeah you just have to sort of
take you know is the violence is overly
violent the gore is overly gory
you know some of it is cartoonish and
doesn't make a lot of sense especially
in a film that might not have had a lot
of that up into that point you know it
might be the only example of violence in
that film and it's weird and it sort of
takes you out of the immersion a bit but
then you just got asked out either
because that would be a criticism of any
other film if it had this
we'd why the [ __ ] that that was my
sideways yeah everybody gory and just
like well this makes sense but yeah then
again I also think yeah that's like
another example of the Gores another
example which if you look at his earlier
movies that pop fiction for example
which he just exploits trout the
entirety of the movie that it does make
it more acceptable that now I'm waiting
for I dude my knows what she wants a
percent of time I didn't I was like
there's gonna be going in here somewhere
mmm and I need to know when it happens
and when it did happen I was just like
[ __ ] yes yes this is like something that
I don't I don't care about Gore in any
other movie but because I respect him so
much as director and I enjoy movie so
much I'm waiting for it mmm because I
will enjoy it because I almost feel like
he enjoyed doing it because that's his
thing you know thing is that Tarantino
tends to use the same characters all the
same actors loves using the same actors
almost surprise time I know Jackson
wasn't in this movie no it was I think
one thing I noticed I had never noticed
before
it was yeah it was inglorious basterds
that in yes Tarantino sometimes does
another trove is he will occasionally
just have a narrator come in at some
point in the film and then a particular
scene and then there's never to be heard
of again
Terrell Jackson narrates and it's just
elderly those actually yeah just just
has a few lines now it's something is
going on and you know I think it's I
mean it's the background of Hugo
Stiglitz you know it just tells you all
about this guy you know killed some
Nazis and put a German prison for it and
then no to be seen again and you just
you know that's a typical one you know
he uses same characters use Brad Pitt
before you use Leo but fourth definitely
and nice probably not so obvious one in
this one it was nearly using the
character but uma thurman's daughter you
know the hippies or to you the ones at
the end to go to murder them and the one
who runs away drives away thermos
daughter yeah our Fair Play edition oh
yeah she's also we are from stranger
things the one that works in the ice
cream yeah I heard that yeah I didn't
know that yeah Kurt Russell's been used
before cameras in yeah hey filet yeah
he uses characters or actors all the
time and you know he can write yeah he
knows who he likes you know he likes
working with and I have heard that he is
a particularly difficult director to
work with so I suppose you know you make
sense that it sticks to the ones that
works but then again make it also what I
would say is like I think Tim Roth had
some deleted scenes for this one as well
Alfre yeah in regards what we were
saying about like artistic tendencies do
you think you'd enjoy a kind of
typically structured movie directed by
Tarantino yeah I mean instance is a
movie you know it has an objective it
has an objective quite early on
established we're gonna Joe's a pretty
normally structured movie as well
fair play man yeah and their minds
ignore me but yeah I don't know man I
don't know like I'm trying to think if
there's another another director that
has like artistic tendencies that I
actually look forward to I don't really
pay that much [ __ ] attention to
directors to be fair hmm I just know
that good or not there's nothing going
good movies man I mean yeah I think
there are some directors that have you
know particular things that you expect
for them not all of them good yeah you
got Michael Bay and there's gonna be
explosions yeah that's not really an
artistic expression it's just James
Cameron it's gonna be expensive yeah
true M night Shyamalan there will be a
twist the you know or maybe it's just
gonna be [ __ ] awful so what's your
opinion man what's film what makes a
good film hmm I think to a lot of extent
you have to accept that there is and a
certain hate using the phrase jeunesse a
qua with films in that there arose a
structure to a lot of them you know you
wanna you want to be able to follow it
for sure mmm-hmm like with anything
there will be pricks there will be
people you know I mean me and Lauren we
went to the Saatchi Gallery maybe a few
months ago
I started this year saatchi gallery
what's her it's a gallery in London has
a gallery okay cool
and we went there and you know had
certain exhibits on you know the changed
exhibits all the time so you never know
what's really gonna be on there maybe
it's not caught something up for a month
so she'd been playing times before yeah
we went and I went around if I can hate
it it's not [ __ ] pretty much like not
not that I'm not I hate you did the
experience you know I was up for going
but I hated the exhibits that were there
at the time because you know one thing
in particular where it was like here's
it's a flower pot I think the pain was
called like a flower pot in front of a
wardrobe you know and I looked at it and
it looked like it had been painted by a
child and you know it looked it just
looks [ __ ] looked I can't even
understand you know I could probably do
better than that and you know and I can
understand with some some you know some
pieces of art it's you can have
something that's quite minimalist be
something that's quite good but I
couldn't see the good in it I could I
really you know I didn't I wasn't trying
to be afraid I was really trying to see
and I couldn't see the good in it I was
like there is nothing exceptional about
this piece of art if a child had done it
and you know if five minutes before now
he took this down and put replace it of
something that five-year-old child done
and said this is the piece of art I
wouldn't know the difference because it
looks [ __ ] awful yeah and they'll and
the fact that it's made it to this very
famous gallery means that there's a lot
of pricks down online who've gone
fantastic that's beautiful yeah it's
amazing it's crazy it's free and you
know those place stuff there if I can it
didn't sting careful hmm
and an a you know I think the same was
gonna recover films yeah we are we are
we Tarantino pricks maybe I think we are
to an extent but I think I think time to
you can get away with it in the law
respects yeah because maybe maybe maybe
you can have different different ideas
of what is good about film because you
can appreciate different aspects of a
film
we were painting you know maybe you can
appreciate the use of color you know you
can appreciate the particular style of
art that they've used political style
shading and I don't know enough about
art to appreciate those things so if I
just see a ship painting of a flower pot
I'll say [ __ ] and if I appreciated
shading in color a bit more maybe I
wouldn't think of a so [ __ ] but it was
[ __ ] yeah yeah with a film you know you
have cinematography you can say
objectively cinematography is fantastic
fantastic service ography acting
fantastic acting great acting story yeah
true you've got a s with films you've
got like a lot more elements in that
what you can determine was what makes a
good film so like yeah if the story was
a bit off but the acting and the
cinematography was great alright cool
man two out of three we did what is a
good film yeah but yeah like I tell you
what doesn't make a [ __ ] film not
necessarily what makes a good from what
doesn't make a [ __ ] feel much [ __ ]
pisses me off when people don't like the
ending man mm-hmm
when it's like an awesome film so
cinematography was good story was good
acting was good like the shots were good
like the colour the vibrance was good
the tension was good man the timing was
good the sounds were good the surprise
was good the twists were good and then
at the end it didn't happen the way like
you wanted it to happen and you're like
ah [ __ ] okay
what [ __ ] awesome movie and then like
[ __ ] [ __ ] hated that movie and how
can that happen at the end mm you know
yeah but scrap the end yeah what do you
think of the movies you saw a [ __ ] like
it's the end of [ __ ] yeah cuz the end
was [ __ ] just because the end was [ __ ]
so from 99 to 100% that one percent was
[ __ ] it makes the whole movie [ __ ] yeah
I mean you know it's it's just very
basic psychological principle of recency
you know the last thing he saw is the
most impactful thing that you remember
about a thing you know your last
interaction was a person is going to be
very impactful you know if you've had
limited amounts of interaction with
someone you know I [ __ ] don't like a
guy because last time he did this mm I
guess you're right maybe the last 10
times he's been all right but if he did
something practice last time maybe don't
like him so much
yes and a good show I can understand why
people are like that
I disagree ver I've had I've known
people before that have not even bad
endings but sad endings
mhm endings where the character dies you
know people have associated that with
well it was sad therefore it was bad
okay that doesn't make sense not like it
was upsetting but it was good because it
made you feel sad yeah it was a good
film because you were invested in it
enough that when that character died you
were upset about it that's a good film
nice man someone's a fun time i
Hollywood's pretty good film it's good
fun I enjoy that you know I I I think
sometimes with Tarantino films they they
can they can be overly long I'm very
conscious of that now only because with
Lauren I made a specific point to watch
it at one o'clock in the afternoon I do
yeah we watched it whoo yeah and I was
like thank [ __ ] we watched it too man
because if we've watched it like seven
like I would have been I want it
struggling so yeah man good movie
Tarantino stood of Beast acting was good
shots were good I mean is there's
nothing wrong with having critiques
about a movie there doesn't make it a
bad movie yeah I feel like this film had
so much hype that like if there's a
couple critiques or Mike Lee is a [ __ ]
movie but yeah man I think it was dope
yeah yeah I don't you know it's by no
means my favorite Tarantino film oh yeah
for sure you know it's one I will watch
another time you know when it comes out
sure I'll watch it again I'm not gonna
hang a poster in my wall but yeah it was
a solid movie for sure you know enjoyed
it it was pretty much in a lot of ways
the movie I expected it to be
yeah same here dude - same here zoom has
wrapped this [ __ ] up I think we could
go for a little while no man no it was
pretty good podcast man so I can sick